e
um good morning and welcome to a work
session for the special committee on the
Department of Children Youth and Family
I am representative Erica Leon and I am
now serving as the chairman of this
committee and I would like to rep
welcome representative David love he is
a new member of this
committee so as we had our meeting um
last time we heard lots of very very
compelling testimony we heard people who
went through a lot with their families
and went through a very difficult
process that was not helped by um lack
of transparency and not understanding
what was going on um I think that this
committee has great opportunities to
make it so the process is better
understood and also to find areas where
we can help and we can help make it more
clear what should happen what shouldn't
happen and to make the process easier
for people in DCF for the families
interacting with them and all the other
s all the other people who are involved
in this
process um first I want to speak about
the administration of Oaths um in RSA
1414 the legislature is allowed to
administer Oaths um there is no specific
guidelines about how when where or what
is done with those Oaths however there
is RSA
6411 which is for perjury I do want to
stop for a moment and say that part one
article 30 of the New Hampshire
Constitution protects the speech of
legislators and not the public when they
are in the chambers so when you're
testifying into a committee and you are
the public your speech is not protected
from other courts and other bodies I
actually thought that it was um so it
was quite enlightening for me to realize
that that protection is only for
legislators because legislators need to
be able to speak and not be afraid of
the consequences outside of the
consequences of this court of the
general court in
2017 Oaths were used in disciplinary
hearings um when that was going before
the legislative Ethics Committee
that was a matter of deciding whether to
expel people or to take other action
from members of the general court uh for
what was said in the general court and
what was done article 30 of the part 1
of our constitution says that the
freedom of deliberation speech and
debate in either House of the
legislature is so essential to the
rights of the people that it cannot be
the foundation of any action complaint
or prosecution in any other Court or
Place whatsoever but that means means
that your speech in the legislature can
be an action within the general court um
and that was a very straight line
application of the
oath now moving to the idea um of
perjury so perjury under RSA 6411
provides for a class B felony for false
statements under oath or affirmation
which are false or inconsistent unless
the person believes the statement to be
true there's a little bit more into the
statute but I just wanted to sort of
condense it down to my understanding of
that so that we could have a better
discussion about that process so a class
B felony carries a sentence of up to
seven years of prison and up to a $4,000
fine um it's quite significant with that
um Not only would you lose your freedom
from that You' also lose your ability to
have a firearm you'd lose an opportunity
to I believe work in the schools lots
and lots and lots of different things um
actually the schools I'm not certain but
I think I remember at I I think I may or
may not be remembering that on the
qualifications for
teachers so given how serious those
penalties are it makes sense that there
is a protection for statements that are
believed to be true because if a person
truly believes that what they're saying
is true then they shouldn't be spending
seven years in prison if they were
wrong that makes it very complicated to
pursue and likely very costly both for
the state and for the individuals
involved to um either bring a perjury
charge or defend against a perjury
charge there's also the problem about
whether or not it's equally applied if
perjury is unequally applied to certain
viewpoints then that becomes even more
problematic and have would have a
chilling impact on
speech in order to get to that perjury
charge I believe that the Attorney
General would need to bring charges and
given how complex and costly it is um I
it seems like it would be a challenge
for that to happen although in sign in
serious and significant cases um it
definitely has that
pathway so right now we're looking at an
issue where we want to make sure that
people are truthful so that we know
what's going on and that is a lot of the
intent of the Oaths um but there's not a
straight line path about exactly how it
would be handled even if you knew that
somebody was saying something that was
not true was inconsistent and that
logically they should be able to tell
the difference between the two as
legislators we have to make a decision
between that and I think that there may
be some Parallels for that in the child
abuse situations um we actually had a
what I found to be fascinating debate on
the second bill of the calendar on last
week on House Bill
1659 it really seemed to highlight the
fact that child abuse allegations um
sort of hang around as allegations and
aren't necessarily brought to a
conclusion whether to find that it's
unfounded or to bring criminal charges
um I heard from people that if there's
no broken bones nothing will be done and
that's terrifying it's absolutely
terrifying if we had a better process in
place we may not know Harmony
Montgomery's name because that might
have been taken care of and families who
have lost their children parents who
have been alienated and isolated from
them might not have lost their
family so if we as a committee are able
to look at this and figure out a way to
standardize practices and figure out a
way to get more clarity then I think
that would benefit both those children
who are abused and those families that
are separated
unnecessarily um I think that it draws
an interesting parallel but I think that
that should be our highest
priority um so my my biggest part is I
want to figure out how we can set guard
rails how can we have innocent person be
able to clear their name if there's no
abuse especially in those cases where we
have that bill that's moved on to the
Senate where there's people who who do
make malicious reports it happens from
time to time not all the time but it
does happen how do you clear somebody
when it's absolutely absolutely true
that everybody that other people
witnessed the situation and it did not
happen if there's already a policy in
place that's great and we have a place
to start and then how how what do we do
when claims aren't forwarded to the
court system if there is something that
is a felony because it's assault of a
child under 13 that should not be kept
within the in my opinion that should not
be kept within the department there
needs to be a clear policy where that is
forwarded through um obviously there's
members here that have far more
knowledge of this than I do but when I
was looking through the statutes the
district courts have the role of having
a hearing and determining whether to
forward on criminal charges to the
Superior Courts perhaps there needs to
be a policy in that perhaps there
already is but um I would really love to
hear from the members of this committee
about their thoughts about this process
and um hopefully be able to inform me
some because uh we have some uh some
people with a lot of knowledge in child
and family law and um and within the
Weber thank you and and I'm well aware
that I have a small amount of knowledge
which is often the dangerous thing um
it's sounds to me uh first of all I
agree with you that those are areas that
I think could be looked at uh and other
people may have other priorities that we
may also decide we want to look at that
maybe of higher priority but the two
that have been spoken
of um I think it would be helpful for us
to have people come and explain to us
what the actual guidelines are that
DCF investigative
workers are given for when a case is
founded and when unfounded and that may
be something that folks from children
and family law have already um explored
and if if we're breaking new ground you
can just give us the benefit of your
knowledge but I think that that's well
worth exploring because I think that
this is the nub of one of the really
most difficult aspects of this
work and you've you've already set out
both sides of it on the one side you
know the the process can be weaponized
um either by parents who are angry or
divorc or a neighbor who's angry at
their neighbor or anybody else and
that's a very bad thing for the parent
and the family as a whole on the other
hand we certainly want to be sure that
um actual cases of abuse are
investigated and followed up on and you
know one of the things that I'm
remembering and I don't know exactly
where it sits now now but from my last
service on a committee with a similar
charge was the issue of can an
investigative worker go into the home
and under what circumstances and how
thoroughly they can look at that and on
the one hand we have the protections of
the family in the home and on the other
hand we have the protection of the child
so I'd love to hear more about the
current state of affairs and what people
think they are allowed to do and not
allowed to do so I think that's very
much worthy of of looking at and then I
think that figuring out the referral
process because as we know everybody in
the state is a mandated reporter so if I
suspect abuse I am required even though
just a private citizen to report that to
dcyf and I know that in many cases dcyf
makes a referral uh to the police
department for criminal investigation
because that's where the criminal
charges are investigated and to uh a
state's attorney for for
prosecution uh it h so I think
understanding that process better would
also be very useful for us as a starting
point and I would I would think that
perhaps at our next meeting we could ask
for people to come and help us with that
um thank you I think that's a wonderful
idea and I think we also might want to
have the chiefs of police come and speak
about how they handle those referrals
because we don't know if there the
handoff is uh has everything it needs uh
um yes representative Greg sorry I
turned my name tag back around thank you
madam shwom so one thing that you know I
want to I want to balance out the fact
that I know we want the truth or what
people think of the truth one of the
things in looking at cases of abuse is
what people think is abuse I will say as
far as um how other states compare and
New Hampshire compares are what we um
our definitions of abuse are decades
behind where other places are and in a
lot of times when you talk to someone
who has been accused of abuse or even
you see court cases or anything like
that what you'll notice is a common lack
of insight so what I look at and say
gosh that kid has a a bruise on his face
that's abuse an abuser might say he was
smart off to me and it's my job to teach
him a lesson so there's a break in what
is appropriate and what is abused so
that's one of those hard things when I
look at administering an oath I mean
it's our job to um ask the questions to
listen to what somebody wants to say and
then also to talk to people that have
knowledge of particular things because
you know what is one person's perception
is somebody else's very different
perception and we get that a lot in
child and family law because we do see a
lot of abuse and that stuff but there is
a Hallmark in abuse ERS and um there are
two actually one an abuser will often
times say they've been abused and also
um a lack of insight into their own
behavior being Abus so those are two
things to keep in mind as we look at
this thank you that's helpful that's the
cycle of abuse and we need to figure out
how to break it
right representative
kofalt thank you I think um related to
some of the um topics that you mentioned
um Madam chair the um
you know there there is the the bill
that we just sent over to the other body
uh regarding false reports um I am I am
also concerned that
um a smart person who who wants to file
false reports will perhaps not file
false reports directly but will will
speak to a mandated reporter and I I've
actually heard of instances of this
happening
repeatedly um and
dcyf doing what I think is appropriate
under the circumstances which is
investigating those um over and over
again um finding no fault over and over
again nevertheless I think it is
consuming DCF resources and I I'm not
sure what the solution to that is but it
it it it does seem to me that it's
something that ought to be within the
purview of this committee as
well thank
panck thank you um chairman um I heard
that 90% of the abuse reports are false
allegations how do we tease that out and
the judges know
that judges know that 90% of the abuse
uh
allegations are there but in order to
protect that 10% that it's with is real
abuse it seems to me like everybody is
paying the price how do we assure that
this isn't going to continue to happen
and I speak from
experience um a false allegation that
was given about my son and I was there
and what was alleged never happened and
it cost a lot of money to to clean that
up and the judge even said they know but
they just have to be absolutely certain
to protect that other 10% what can we do
to protect the the innocent
that yeah I was going to ask a question
but well I I just want to be sure that
we are understanding the difference
between a false report which is
materially false as in your case and an
unfounded report which is a report where
they simply cannot
document what happened so I just want
all of us to keep that firmly in mind
and I'm sorry for the interruption and
that's precisely what I was about to ask
um do you know if those were if it's
that 90% are false or if n if only 10%
are found to have
abuse if you don't know the number
that's fine okay I I think a lot of that
is that big area in between the known
and on either end representative Greg
and then representative gr grman and
there's actually different levels of
finding so it's not just black or white
it's not just well this is unfounded
this is founded this is false even there
are different um there are very
different levels and I think that's
going be really imperative to have
somebody from actually DCF come in and
talk to us about that um what levels
they have and um I know that on here you
even have like how an innocent person
can clear their name there are certain
things when there's certain levels of
findings it's not really a registry it
just is in that DCF file so if something
comes up again they're looking for a
pattern like if okay it might not
necessarily be founded like somebody's
been pinching their child for punishment
and leaving bruises so okay now they're
going to come back and they're going to
tell that parent that's not appropriate
parenting now if it happens again it's
still in the files they can see this has
come up before and that helps but there
are levels of findings it's not just one
way or the other so it's what they can
prosecute is what I think was that 10%
that can but but there are levels so
thank you that's helpful and I
definitely want us to learn more about
that same question representative Gman
representative
love yeah thank you madam chair uh I
think representative Greg uh hit on
something that would uh when you know
she was talking about just what is child
abuse you know in some states uh you
know you can whack your kid in the head
uh other other states you can't uh I
think we have to Define that and and
punching a child uh should certain to me
as a felony um you know they they they
should do a long stretch of time and uh
if and if we had something like that how
many would be alive today uh also um you
know um
representative turn your name Weber
that's
yes uh you know she also mentioned that
you know the the policies you know I
want I want to see the policy Playbook
because uh in my experiences it's all
over the place it changes and uh you
know and I'm one of the ones that had
that no broken bones no hospitalization
there isn't much we can do I had that
happen twice there were knuckle marck on
my daughter's back representative love
let's uh make sure that we keep our role
on the committee separate from our
personal experiences and with the
personal experiences whether it's
professional or personal um a brief
mention is good to know where we are but
the more that we get into it I'd like to
separate it out so that we can make sure
that we're we're keeping clear clear
boundaries and lines okay I I just
wanted to mention that you know that
there was evidence and um you know uh
nothing was done uh was unfounded I was
told and and that's being told to people
I had a woman tell me that a month ago
so you know um we've got to clearly
Define what is actual child abuse and
what isn't thank you representative
Gman thank you madam chair and um to
piggyback along what representative love
was
saying you know the definition of what
founded in New Hampshire and what
unfounded it we'd be remiss to not
mention parental rights um and the issue
that parental rights have in this right
now because Harmony Montgomery was not
protected because of parental rights
that level is not
founded um so the laws need to change if
we want to protect children in those
ways that's up to the general court to
but um thank you and this information um
is that sometimes there are paral there
are concurrent um cases going on one
within DCF and one within the criminal
courts so this is a lot that you know I
I need to learn other people need to
learn and um the more that we can
discuss this and people can understand
what the processes are I think the
better because there'll be less misunder
pure misunderstandings representative
Weber and if we want to go further into
the layers of complexity a child who is
the subject of an abuse and neglect
petition um under the dcyf statutes may
also themselves be the subject of a
juvenile prosecution for something the
child has done so that interjects a jppo
juvenile probation for
officer I never remember what all the
stand for but it's ju juvenile probation
officer into the into the mix uh so
these are really complicated cases and I
applaud
your Clarity and reminding all of us
that we have
to keep firmly in mind not only between
personal and and our roles here but also
all the various roles that come into
play and they're all in the family court
but my my personal opinion is that uh
divorces are not in our purview in this
committee except perhaps as DCF is
sometimes weaponized in a divorce case
which then does become the purview of
this committee um so I think all of us
are going to have to work really hard at
being very clear about which aspect of
which problem we're talking about at any
time because God knows there are enough
problems to go around but um the more
clarity we have the better we can do at
addressing
them yes thank you that is a very good
point and this committee also is not
focused on the family courts it's
focused on
DCF um I believe that in this focus and
getting more clarity um it's a matter of
what feeds into the other systems
because if there is a process in order
to I guess it's a matter of just
understanding the process is best so
that we can make sure that everybody's
rights are protected through in this and
I apologize that I didn't catch
everything uh representative Gman on
that it was basically just that um your
concern that parents rights put Children
at Risk sort of or no sorry just the
concern that right now the big debate in
New Hampshire um and across the country
as well but the whole parental rights
versus the rights of the child
and
um
unfounded findings in many cases
are situations where there are signs of
hitting slapping but it's it's not
founded by the the level that the law in
New
Hampshire calls for and so the the push
back to that are parental rights because
folks want to maintain their rights and
versus that's giving children more
rights to protect them oh thank you I
think a lot of that comes down to the
rights and you never have the right to
harm any person unless it is in direct
self-defense and then that is only in
order to stop the harm that is being
done um and as I was looking at the
statutes assault of a child under 13 is
treated differently which I don't know
what the thoughts were going into that
but it's a lot less likely that you're
in an actual back and forth physical
situation with somebody under 13 than
you are maybe a 15-year-old child who is
stronger than the parents and knows and
knows that they know more than the
parents because that's what being 15 is
Right representative
Weber not I will just say that the the
definition of abuse is in the statute
and
um abused child means any child who has
been sexually abused intentionally
physically injured which does not have
the more nuanced discussions that we've
been having which is why we need to
understand more about how this is
applied psychologically injured uh so
that the child exhibit symptoms of
emotional problems physically injured by
other than accidental means or subjected
by any human to human trafficking or
subjected to an act prohibited by RSA
632 a10d and I have no idea what that is
but I'm sure it's terrible um but I
think that you know I have some
knowledge of how the statute evolved at
least sort of 10 years ago when we were
looking at this because when we started
then if you want to talk about
Antiquated at that point um under 169 C2
the purpose the highest purpose was the
preservation of the family unit and that
was the highest purpose over
everything and we are all certainly very
much I'm sure in favor of preserving in
a family unit but only when it can be
done safely and the fight to get the
highest purpose to be protect the safety
of the child was even then very
controversial um and determining it it's
now written determining if the
preservation of the family unit is in
the best interest of the child and of
course it it really very often is and
that's what we should be working for so
these things change their in flux and
they have been been in flux you know
forever but I think taking a good look
at
whether uh they completely reflect what
we think of societal values today is
important and the other thing is that
you know we also have to take into
account the fact that my societal values
and the values of everybody else in this
room are probably somewhat
different um having been spanked
regularly as a child and been proud of
it but only when only when I knew it was
coming and chose not to stop doing
whatever I'd been told not to do and
that was a different time and a
different way of looking at things um
and it was only with the SP with the
flat of the hand on a clad bottom so um
you know all of those things make a
difference and and societally you know
we are now a nation where there are
awful lot of different kind of cultural
references representative Greg thank you
madam chairman
so one of the things that I in in coming
into the special committee and I hope
this is okay to say what my hopes for
was in looking at this I think that
there are certainly we've seen both both
ends of the spectrum because that's what
you hear about the most not you know the
kind of the middle and what what the the
norm is and I I think we can all get
ideas you know whether or not you've
looked at the harmony Montgomery case
and said why did they not do more or you
know someone that has been arranged from
their kids and why didn't they they do
more but like to check that bias at the
door and just really listen and I think
it would be really helpful to get dcyf
in here not under the precursor that
they're going to be in a tribunal but
let's find out like what is their what
are their mandates what what does it
take for them to intervene are there
certain levels what is their follow-up
look I'd really like to have one session
where we have them in here and we can
ask them these questions and ask
procedurally what they're required to do
or not to do I think that would be
incredibly helpful if we can kind of
check whatever bias we have from the
news at the door and just say what is
this and I think that would be super
helpful thank you I agree um as I was
looking related to one of the bills that
I sat in on a finance they actually do
have the policies and procedures manual
on for
DCF um it's not one document so it's a
little hard to do a search and find on
it in order to see what we need um I
will send a link of that to everybody on
the committee and to the administrative
rules and then once we're all thoroughly
confused we'll have DCF come in and uh
try and explain to us what it is that
they do uh because because I do know
that having it in practice and having in
writing sometimes there's a disconnect
and sometimes we can help with that
representative Weber and I just had one
other historical note that came into my
mind and left again when we had the
commission on uh child abuse fatalities
10 years ago or whenever it was one of
the things we discovered was that uh at
one of the very early meetings because
we had people from DCF and we had people
from the local police departments in the
room at the same time sitting here not
doing anything else and they actually
talked to each other uh there was a
certain amount of discussion in the
audience about how the procedures of one
of those was not helpful in meshing with
the other one and they realized just by
talking to each other that all they had
to do was change their procedures and I
think it was around the issue of when
things are reported or how particularly
in off hours uh but you know when you
have those people together with some
time where they can focus as opposed to
doing all the other things it can be
really helpful in creating easy and
sensible Solutions where there are some
uh leaving us only with the ones that
are really really difficult thank you
and I agree it's probably those handoffs
where we have the most missed
opportunities um because it is really
easy to look at these within silos as
they go to different committees and
they're dealt with with separate
committees um just the perspective is
somewhat different and I think that by
having this special committee that's not
necessarily looking at any particular
bills we have a better opportunity to
talk to everybody who's involved and
make sure that they have the appropriate
empowerment and the appropriate
restraints so that one group isn't
assuming that somebody else is taking
care of certain situations um
because because we need to make sure
that um that whoever's in the police
department handling the reports isn't
thinking that it's being taken care of
by somebody else and we need to make
sure we basically need to make sure that
involved thank you um so with this the
most important so the takeaways that I'm
seeing from this are that I need to set
the policies and procedures to everyone
and the administrative
rules that we need to schedule a meeting
when we can get um probably let's see
how many of the stakeholders we can have
for that between DCF the office of the
child advocate who I know is watching on
the live stream because they weren't
able to be here in person today um
and and we'll see who else seems to be
an appropriate fit as well but I'll put
a big open invitation probably the
police Chiefs Association would be
recommendation fantastic our amazing
committee researcher has already reached
out to make sure that everybody's aware
um although she hadn't included the the
chiefs of police that was my newer idea
to make sure that they're also on board
um so with that we'll figure out when we
can have sort of a longer meeting that
we know the the public won't be won't be
coming and bringing any insight but
we'll be focusing in on that um so to
get all those different groups figure
out what we need and then ask our
questions representative long thank you
madam chair the um I think it's
important to see what the communication
during all this processes with the
family uh that seems to be a
Detachment um whether it's the caregiver
for the child whether it's the parent
you know what kind of communication is
out there you know we often hear
testimony that
I didn't know what was going on for
three months or I you know I mean it
just seems like a basic uh communication
issue uh and you know these questions
are the million dollar questions they
are and then when you get you know you
get uh legislation to attempt to fix it
and you know it it leans one way or the
other protecting the parents or
protecting the child you know and that's
where the debate ends um but I I think
communication is is a key basic that I
don't suspect happens uh and that could
resolve a lot of uh a lot of things and
also uh with DCF the
um you know how many unfounded over a
period of five years maybe or three
years how many unfounded were bounded a
year later not not the same complaint
but another complaint you know know and
how do they address that do they do that
data do they calculate gez we've been
slipping here you know we got 30% of our
unfounded were founded within the LA you
know three years later you know do we
reassess ourselves um you know how do we
drop that number that's a great point
and then what services are provided to
those families is there a way for them
to come and talk to other people and
discuss their parenting strategies in a
low judgment thing I'm not going to say
no judgment because punching a kid in
the face deserves as much judgment as
you can get and a jail term uh but
there's other areas where there is
disagreement about what's appropriate
and I think having a conversation with
peers and especially with mixed
Viewpoint peers um would be a helpful
way to better understand um and sorry
one other thing for representative long
do you think it would also be helpful to
make sure that in any Communications
with families we have just regular
people that are involved in in letting
us know if they'll actually understand
what that paper work is because for
those of us here who are used to the
legislative words and the forms it's one
thing but for your average family going
through something that's pretty
traumatic it needs we need to make sure
that it's actually reaching them where
they are do you think that that right I
no absolutely I I I do agree U I know
two years ago or three years ago maybe
DCF set up a um constituent um I forget
what they call it it's a constituent uh
group where within DCF I've been very
fortunate people that have called me I
turn them over to them and I don't hear
back from them so that's that's that's
helping relations consti relations okay
wonderful thank you representative Gman
I know you've been waiting
patiently microphone please take on Casa
if Casa would be a stakeholder as well
that we should welcome to the table
thank you I think that's a very good
point I we Pro may actually need to have
a few different days I don't know if we
want to start at those that are most at
the Nexus and then start spreading
beyond that because I'm not sure if
everybody could take the entire day but
if we could do that and then carve out
each of the different interactions that
may be a really good way to to do some
good here representative Greg thank you
and I think when we talk about I think
it's a great idea to see can people
understand this and I I would only
caution us as we go into that that
anybody who's had any kind of trauma in
their life whether it's been a death in
your family you might look back over
what you were understanding or what you
were thinking at that time and think wow
I was basically drunk like I was not
responding the way I would there was a
study years ago about anesthesia they
told people on camera like what the
rests of anesthesia were and then had
them come in two weeks after their
surgery and said um so did you
understand and it was in there you're
going to be paralyzed like you were
paralyzed during the surgery and they're
like well nobody told me that and they
went back they showed them that you know
you read this they showed them we talked
about this and and they're like No this
must have all been doctored so there is
something in our brain when we're
stressed that kind of shuts off so I
would be interested they might have a
way that they think you know works with
the lay person but are they are there
other things that they're doing besides
just one way of learning you know one
way of talking about it that might might
help because we really all do have that
block and we kind of get tunnel vision
when we're stressed out so that's a very
good point I know there was some
discussion about the materials that are
supposed to be given to the families
perhaps it's a matter of of making sure
that those are materials are both
accessible and thorough enough um so
that people can understand and not get
overwhelmed by too much but also be able
to get the additional information they
need representative Weber and I think I
think that there are now um some
processes to help with this and the the
point that was the same point I was
going to make when you were in the
middle of a trauma your memory is not
necessarily what it would be and some of
us have memories that aren't what they
used to be anyway um and then you know
somebody hands you the list of all the
things you're supposed to do after
surgery or or what's going to happen
with your child's case and you take that
home and you're upset and that you can't
find the paper ever again and um I think
that having points of accessibility is
really important and I know that for me
as a as a
legislator uh there are both um Woodsman
in
DHHS who will listen to people's
complaints because they should be and it
and it's a matter of having people find
them and um also uh the office of the
child advocate has been an enormous
resource for constituents who have
brought problems to me and they are
often people who are not their own best
Advocates but they are also people who
have a very valid
concern and I again as your experience
the people that I have said here's the
here's the office of the child advocate
perhaps you should talk to them and let
them know of your concerns both
personally and as a systemic issue and
because they can then say oh we've had
12 complaints about issue a and maybe we
better look at it and and those parents
haven't haven't come back and said yeah
there one more person not listening to
me so that I think those are the
positive avenues that are available for
people and how to make sure people are
well aware of them um are
also fertile ground that's a very good
point representative long thank you
madam chair and on on that
note I mean I find the
employees sometimes stressed out go at
it negatively I I you know I you know to
it's tough keep it in mind that I'm
working for you you know you're you're
you're a resident in New Hampshire and
I'm working for you um you know so when
you diminish that power you know
somebody gets C from dcyf their hair
steps up in the back of their necks oh
my goodness what's going on uh you know
that for that cing to occur you'll get
better results uh I I I know through my
experience having cons call me uh it's
it's been a lack of um you know it's
been a lack of uh uh understanding you
know or you know I know where you are I
can imagine how you're feeling uh I
gotta take that in check you know you're
my 25th call here uh I'm going after you
I it's it's a tough thing to do but I I
think that's so important that training
thank you that's a really good point and
then also making sure that if they were
exposed to really traumatic situation
that that's not impacting their view on
other because we're all humans and we
need to understand our own limitations
and make sure that we're not expecting
these case workers to be super humans
right yes representative Weber and I
think this is probably also out of our
baileywick but I think we ought to keep
it firmly in mind uh when I was doing
this work before the issue was we did
not have enough case workers or enough
positions and everybody was carrying a
case load that was way in excess of
recommended case loads uh according to
nationally recognized standards by a
factor of somewhere between three and 10
and now we had a wonderful um bipartisan
Coalition that created a lot of new
positions now unfortunately we have the
positions and we have the funding and we
cannot fill the positions so once again
we are in that situation where people
are often carrying more cases than the
Optima and therefore having less time to
explain to get to know to establish a
rapport and that also leads to less job
satisfaction and the kind of issues that
you were talking about so that's very
real and it's there I'm not sure what we
can do about it but we need to keep it
in in persp perspective the other thing
that the system has been doing if I
understand it correctly is starting with
the tenure of director
ribom is trying you know we had one
awful case of a father who took his own
life and his child's life because he had
gone to
DCF and was unable to get help because
he was not abusing his child he was
concerned for his child and he couldn't
I mean this makes me want to cry he
could not provide di for his child and
his in his despair he took both lives
and there has been an effort to uh turn
the ship around and say oh we're not
going to wait until everything has
failed we're we're going to offer
services and
interventions well Upstream So a family
that is
struggling has some Services before they
get to that point of desperation because
what we I mean it just seems axiomatic
to me that what we ought to be doing is
making families stronger when they're
intact and offering them the services
that they need to strengthen and bolster
the caring that they already have uh
rather than waiting till things
disintegrate because obviously anytime
we can keep a family intact and
supported that's got to be better for
everybody so um you know I think I think
the early intervention
pieces are again maybe not part of our
our remit we can talk about that but I
think it's something that we ought to
keep clearly in mind is something that
has been proven statist you know there's
a reason that we hire people out of New
Jersey to head
DCF they're eons ahead of us and they
have worked very hard at at the early
intervention side of things because
it's it's ultimately cheaper and it's
healthier for everybody well and I think
that brings up a good point early
intervention that's asked for or going
in and looking for something where your
child says that you're abusing them
because they won't have enough they
don't have enough screen time um because
there there is a significant issue where
there are children who believe that they
should be treated in a certain way with
certain opportunities and and truthfully
and authentically feel that that is
abuse from their parents by limiting
them access to that thing that makes
them happy so um a lot of it is just
things have gotten so out of balance um
with kids with families with parents
with everybody and it's a matter of
trying to figure out how we can get
things back on track I do like that idea
about figuring out a path for people
asking for help uh because in those
situations especially when there's sort
of a binary Choice um here I am and I'm
struggling and if I'm going to do
anything it's that itic how do how do we
make sure that we can help those people
but also not get involved when it's not
an appropriate Choice um and and mam
chair that goes back to the various
levels of
founded um you know there are there are
letters of concern and things like that
where that is that is the the entire
focus of you know this is not abuse but
there are concerns here so we need to um
here here are the things that might help
in that situation and without having a
process for those people who are
specifically reaching out for help
before giving um sort of an accused
thought crime as well for other people
too we need to figure out those balances
um I when you brought up the point about
case load I think that was very
important I think that also needs to be
balanced with workload because it's a
matter of figuring out how these cases
are handled and how the how the work
process works um I'm curious as to
whether whe these are sort of triaged
out to different levels of intensity to
start and once you're triaged into a
certain care path um whether or not
that's sort of locked in and baked into
the cake if there's more flexibility um
and that's something that I'd be really
interested in knowing because if things
are sort of baked into the cake based on
that initial triage what happens if
you've been deal if your casew worker
just came off of a traumatic case and so
they are seeing seeing monsters around
every corner just because of what they
had previously experienced is a family
then triaged into a high level of need
when that may not be appropriate and how
do you move families from those
different levels um if they do exist
within that pathway representative
kofalt thank you madam chair so I I
think all of this is very important
information for us to have as
legislators beyond the scope of this
committee I think it's very important
for us to have a deeper knowledge of the
the issues and mechanisms around DCF
having said that um I I want to just
sort of come back to the the mission of
this committee is really to focus on due
process so I I do believe that these are
these topics are being discussed in in
so far as they touch on due process so
for example you mentioned stress levels
a case worker coming off of an
especially traumatic case um me I think
we we hear about these kinds of
situations in police work all the time
is you know the the the stress of the
moment split-second decision um that
there are stresses with these kinds of
high conflict jobs and that can
potentially impact human behavior
because we're all human um so I think
that in so far as these touch on or
somehow impact due process I think they
are sort of within the direct purview of
the committee I do think that it's good
for us to be mindful of and and learn
about the the standards and processes
and all of this but I I do also want to
make sure that we're careful not to um
not to engage in too much scope creep as
far as the committee's mission is
concerned thank you that's a very good
point um within this classification and
all of that that felt um very direct
to-do process but we do need to make
sure we don't drift too far from that
representative love thank you thank you
madam chair um a few things have been
mentioned here that I'd like to bring
the flip side to the coin uh to uh you
know representative Weber talked about
keeping the family
together well with how many Montgomery
you had three kids living in the
backseat of a car mom and dad are
shooting dope in the front we missed the
line we missed we missed that cut off
point we have to Define that in no
uncertain terms and um you know as a
legislature and um you know when uh
Madam chair was talking about um you
know the
uh I think we have we need to look at
the other end have they become numb and
miss and are they missing a lot uh you
know that this maybe the maybe some
mental health health help for the the
order support supporting the team so
that they can do a better job
representative Greg thank you I keep
saying this is my last thing I'm going
to say and then I'm like oh yeah so I
think with with the respect to due
process I I appreciate and I know that's
the focus I don't think you can truly
understand what we're going to consider
is due process without understanding the
mechanisms of how this entire machine is
working because that is due process so I
think all these pieces that we've said
so far are 100% a part of it because it
could even be a lack of understanding of
what the process is and stuff so I think
we're very much still on the page of
where we should be and I appreciate
everybody's input on that um thank you
and looking at this I think some of that
too is that maybe we don't need to get
get into the definitions of what abuse
is that's something that probably should
be handled separately but looking at
that process based upon the legislation
so we can do that of course if those
definitions are so broad that due
process is being violated then it would
make sense um but if people aren't
appropriately informed of their rights
because they're told once and the
information that they're handed isn't
handed to them then that's a Clearo
process one and comes back to what
representative long was talking about
about making sure that people are well
informed about the process so I I think
that we do need that exploration and
then we'll just try and make sure that
everything stays within that creep so
representative Weber I think I'm I think
you've actually gotten to the N of what
I was going to say I really don't see
how we can go forward given the varying
levels of knowledge of what actually
happens that are on this committee mine
is admittedly very old except in very
small cases that I deal with but uh I
think we need to have a basic
understanding of what the current
process is because I know that in every
discussion that I've ever been part of
due process has been a part of that
discussion the question is let's find
out what we're doing now find out where
the slips are and see if changes need to
be made because of um what we're seeing
in the real world world but I think that
until we all have that same Baseline
that means that we're all on the same
page um it's it's uh you know it's for
us to make assumptions about what is is
not
helpful that is a very good point and um
there were very good materials put
together under process that we all need
to review before we have these
discussions with DCF Office of the child
advocate and everybody who's involved so
that we're both looking at the processes
and making sure that due process is
being followed within that
path repres I would I would submit that
finding out what is being done now is
the starting point and then examining
what is being done now for whether it
comports with due process would be the
way to go because if we have
far-reaching disc discs of due process
in the absence of the focus of what's
actually happening on the ground I think
that that is less helpful and I I think
we come at it from two different
directions one is hearing from people
which we have already started to do and
which we'll be doing throughout and
hearing from the people whose charge it
is is the beginning rather than
beginning with the due process concept
we need to know what's happening and
then see if it's falling short or what
could be done to improve it thank you
and that's why it we need to make sure
that we can have an ongoing dialogue an
ongoing process where um these where
we'll be able to have them come back in
for more discussion over time so that we
can make sure that the policies and
procedures are what they need to do that
they um work appropriately with all of
the other engaged bodies where you're
expecting somebody else will be handling
the situation and making sure that those
rights are protected within that because
when there's more knowledge of what's
Happening you have a much higher
likelihood of people actually following
through and complying with what we're
asking for them because if they don't
understand what's being asked of them
it's really hard for them to expect them
through um so we have five six minutes
before the uh we will be opening it up
to the public I do want to give a
preview of another area that I would
like us to work on um we won't be
meeting over the summer so if we're
digging into this um deep enough and
making making great progress that I may
may wait on the other one until later um
educational neglect is handled within
dcyf even though they are not Educators
um there have been there's been some
work on this in the past um they're the
ones who review a homeschooler portfolio
to determine whether their progress is
appropriate given their age and ability
um and that seems like a mission creep
that's Pro possibly taking away from
these other cases where we're talking
about physical AB abuse or sexual abuse
or something where there is more
training from the case workers um the
idea of seeing about transitioning that
over to the Department of Education may
be a better fit uh because quite frankly
we asked a lot of our case workers
expecting them to be experts in academic
childhood development seems to be a
stretch especially when we're having
trouble those roles and we have case
load um we we have case load issues as
well so that's something sort of to keep
in the back of the mind I'll get more
information to everybody on that as well
but I want to make sure that we do have
appropriate due process for families
that are going through um these more
physical related issues and by making
sure that we're not tasking Cas workers
with something that is with outside of
their wheelhouse that can have better
focus make sure that it is better
considered um and just make sure that we
are moving things to the correct areas
so that one I can I'll leave to the
Future um but representative
Weber I just want to be sure that we're
we're talking about similar things
because
um educational neglect in the sense I
mean what what I have seen and heard
about with respect to dcyf which doesn't
mean that there is another things going
on it just means I haven't heard about
it is the look at whether a child is is
actually being schooled at all and uh
there are any number of cases that come
to dcyf because there is no schooling
and that is an issue of neglect I think
when we're talking about I would agree
with you 100% if we're talking about
reviewing how a home schooler is being
homeschooled and whether that's
appropriate or not I wasn't aware that
anybody was actually reviewing that so
we need to find out more about what's
actually happening with that but the the
cases that I have heard of in Casa work
where there's an issue of educational
neglect it has been because not only is
the child theoretically enrolled in in a
public school and not attending but um
they also or or they may have because I
tend to hear about cases with old
children um there are cases where the
parent is unable to govern the behavior
of their kid and and has said well I'm
homeschooling because that's the easiest
thing to say and and I think that is a
very different case from somebody
overseeing the whole homeschool process
which is something else again um thank
you that's a good Insight so this is a
process where if somebody has a
complaint aain about why are these
children in in their yard during the
school day that goes to
DCF um so homeschoolers and people who
simply are not attending school all are
funneled into this through the treny um
issues so this is one where um after we
get a good grasp of what's happening
with the um with the whole abuse process
then that's something that we can look
into and get some Buy in from the
Department of Education as well and from
all of those that are involved to
homeschool legal defense Association has
represented families in New Hampshire
who have had um some interesting
interactions with dcyf regarding
educational neglect so balancing all of
this makes sense um because quite
frankly um we we can get into that full
discussion later but the idea that
they're reviewing and trying to
understand if a child who um may be
working on some more remedial remedial
writing skills but they're doing physics
at an age that's far soon
um if that is appropriate for their age
and ability because they can't write to
save their life oh they're working on it
they're making progress but that's hard
but when it comes to numbers they're a
wizard and I went to MIT there were
plenty of kids like
that we don't have good social skills
either um so with that um I will get
those policies and administrative rules
out I would like to get an idea of any
specific areas where people have
questions or concerns so so that we can
sort of um let the DCF the office of the
child advocate and others who are
involved know which areas we um are
starting off with some questions but I
would like to have an overview from them
when we're able to schedule that um we
are we can now close our work session um
I know everybody's waiting patiently I
will um actually open at about um 11:05
because I need to run down the hall uh
before we start the hearing and I want
to make sure that everybody from the
public who's here in order to share
their share um with us are appropriately
heard so with that we'll start up again
you
e
um thank you and welcome to the regular
meeting of the special committee on the
department of children youth and
families if you saw from our work
session we do have people coming in and
out because people do have other
meetings that are scheduled and some
people have certain commitments so if
there's somebody who is coming in or
somebody who is leaving um during this
time please don't take that personally
um we have all of this that will be
available for review so that everybody
will be watching and seeing what you
have to say even if you had to leave
even if they have to leave to get to
another meeting um with that we um we
have four people that have given me a
card to speak um with the amount of time
just so that we can make sure that we
can balance everybody's time I will let
you know when you've reached the amount
of time that you've requested and then
I'll let you finish up with your
statement then we will ask you questions
um if you feel that you don't have
enough you haven't said enough um well
first we're all people our brains can
only handle so much at one time so it's
far more effective for to give us three
minutes of information than 10 and far
more helpful to have 10 minutes in of
information than half an hour because we
can only retain so much of what you have
to say and so by keeping it focused we
can get your clear message from you um
this is just always important whenever
you're sharing information with others
um so the other part is that I know that
there is some interest around the area
of Oaths um the state law allows for the
provision of the legislature to
administer an oath uh but the only way
that that really can be handled and
brought forth is under perjury and under
perjury which is a class B felony with a
sentence of up to 7 years in prison and
a fine of up to
$4,000 um there is protections for
statements that are believed to be true
even if they are false or inconsistent
with other information that makes it a
very very difficult case to deal with
whether or not you were trying to bring
that um from the attorney general or if
you were trying to defend against that
because there's a Viewpoint difference
in and
um and there's the potential of how it
could be applied so there is always that
challenge um I am coming into this with
the expectation that people are going to
be truthful and give me the information
that they can and the information that
they want the more that you can back
anything up with documents that goes to
further reinforce what you say but I ask
you to please be careful if you provide
any documents they become part of the
public record if there are information
that you and any that you say here as
well is on the YouTube channel that is
saved for the legislature and is
available to the public as I stated
earlier in our work session before many
of you arrived part one article part one
article 30 of the New Hampshire
Constitution only protects the speech of
legislators and not the public in this
body um so please be careful of what you
do say because I don't want your
testimony to then cause problems for you
especially if you have Active cases um
um I really care that you all are here
taking time out of your day to talk with
us and help us to try and improve due
process within DCF but I also want to
make sure that um I I just want to make
sure that everybody is as safe and
protected as
possible so um with this I will not be
administering Oaths people may say
whatever they would like in their
testimony and representative
Weber and I just had one other point of
clarification if you approve of it Madam
chair which is that it seemed to me that
at some
points uh in earlier testimony we went
farther a field into the entire family
court process and I understand that they
are
interrelated but it seems to me that the
um charge of this committee is DCF so if
there is a concern about DCF being uh
weaponized in a divorce casee that is
something we ought to know about but
just the process of people's divorces or
other family court matters of which
there are any number are outside of our
our scope um so what we need to do is
focus very carefully on on the
interactions with dcyf and how that
impacts the lives of whoever's testim
testifying thank you that is a very good
point if you're getting into court
procedure
um while there is a there there may very
likely be a due process tie-in we are
trying to focus on the dcyf involvement
and um almost what I think of is the
feeder system uh Because unless there's
an interaction with DCF you're not in um
that's that seems to be what um is part
of the process for people who have had
challenges in the family courts so I'd
like to keep this um focused more on the
dcyf aspects of this um and as I said
before I I saw one card that um is is on
the longer side um there are several of
us that do have other appointments and
other meetings so that if anybody leaves
it's not a personal issue um and so
first I will call Representative Leah
minutes your microphone's not on
I swear to tell the truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth so help
me
God thank you madam
chair um so sitting here listening um as
you all know I asked the speaker for
this committee after the people
instructed me to Via notices that they
provided drawing attention and making um
showing uh controverting evidence
that due process as required by part one
Article 15 of the New Hampshire City
Constitution is being
violated it's not being
provided before you take any Liberties
or rights from people you must find
guilt by a trial by
jury that's in a court of record that
moves by common law everything else that
is being talked about right now is
extraneous details fact finding is done
by juries um you know whether uh the
circumstances of a case provide for
leniency that's determined by a
jury so we're get the committee is
getting way off track and to say that
Family
Court discussion has to be limited is
totally antithetical to the whole point
of this committee it's about due process
related to
DCF and DCF takes children by bringing a
petition to Family Court where there is
no trial by jury and the facts are not
found by a jury and it doesn't move
under common law and the
evidence is picked and choosed as to how
it's going to be
weighed okay so all of those things are
way off track the first thing that the
the members of this committee need to
understand is you already all swore oath
to protect those rights under part one
Article 15 you swore already now you've
been given notice now you're receiving
it again
you swore if you break that you're
breaking the
contract okay that's
maladministration so that is the main
responsibility of this committee is to
ensure that the people are getting trial
by jury before they're I mean think of
it losing a child is akin to capital
punishment that's something that needs
to be dealt with in a trial by jury you
can't take rights you can't take
Liberties need a trial by jury um
um the only thing that can change this
um at maybe part one Article 15 should
be read every five minutes in this
committee so it keeps your eye on the
ball um after hearing at the last
meeting uh the testimony of Andrew Noyes
um it laid out very eloquent eloquently
what is required by the Constitution so
I recommend going back and listening to
that maybe transcribing it and keeping
it taped in front of you um I reached
out to to to dcfb email after last uh at
after the last meeting and I and I said
after I heard what I heard today I I can
only conclude that what's happening is
very unlawful and please I'm bringing it
to your attention as well please make it
stop um I asked I'm going to extend you
to 10 minutes because you're already at
three minutes so wow okay thank you
you're welcome um the legislature used
to hear this is really what's going on
is is the people are coming and
saying Hell help our rights are being
violated you promised that you would
ensure that we have these rights at all
times and that you would be at all times
accountable to us and that if there is
um an abreg of Rights happening that
without delay we would deal with it and
it's been lost throughout history uh in
the way that things have been run in
this in this body but redress of
grievance is our first job in the
Constitution writing laws is second and
at the beginning of this country and the
the very first Act was to deal with the
redress of grievance and then all the
Committees that formed were not subject
matter committees they were committees
named after the person whose issue had
been brought forth they met sometimes
they would make special acts just to to
fix this per thing this wrong for this
one person you know this is completely
doable um and and you'll get
I don't want to get too far off
but that that's really your main job
here is to ensure the Constitutional
protections of the people all the other
stuff
like a a jury of your peers is the best
body to determine
of uh whether you've committed a harm
that deserves severe punishment or you
know lesser punishment juries find the
facts they're they're a representative
body of the people as well and and that
trial by jury is such an integral part
of um our rights in this in this country
I mean the the courts of common pleas
existed here before the um instituting
of of this form of government the
Republican government so I mean it's
carried from from the English common law
and and the the the fundamental
principles behind the Constitution are
the common law and the constitution in
part one article 30 says the people um
it says a frequent recurrence to the
fundamental principles of the
Constitution and a constant adherence to
Justice moderation Temperance industry
frugality and all social virtues are
indispensably necessary to preserve the
blessings of liberty and good government
that's what the people did with those
notices they pointed us to the
fundamental principles and and they're
they're saying help us now fix this so
for for dcyf to have
um administrative
tribunals where they find fact they
they're acting as investigator which is
usually um executive branch function
right law enforcement then they're
acting as the judge and jury and they're
penalty in the form of putting you on
that
registry which limits your job um
abilities volunteer abilities maybe
potentially your custody of your
children if you get divorced
later all of that steps into the realm
of Taking
Liberties and it requires a trial by
jury there's a federal case um that was
already uh found ruled in against the
SEC it's SEC versus Jesy and it's in the
Supreme Court now and it's looking at
this too um Congressman Thomas Massie
just had a reigning in the
administrative um State kind of
committee that is looking at these
issues too and he received notices and
so the you take the instructions and you
you follow what the people are telling
you um if they're showing you that their
rights that you swore to protect are not
being protected and and stay focused on
that and stay focused on what the trust
IND denture that is the New Hampshire
Constitution that all of the
Constitutions are their Express trust
what they say in part two is is what is
um you know how government is to operate
in part one
is reserve back to the people we're not
supposed to drift into any part of part
one to to mess with it or or you know
shortcut it you have to keep it the way
the way it
is um so DCF if they if they get a call
the way I see it they get a call um they
go in they can they can ask voluntarily
to to work with the family and see you
know we understand there's problem going
on um and the family can voluntarily
work with them but if not you you have
to get you have to do a sworn affidavit
to confer jurisdiction to the court for
them to then issue a warrant and then
have an investigation so like you you
can't even have a warrant without
someone making an accusation and
actually in this state everyone is a
mandated reporter um it's not just
that's just a common misconception that
it's only certain people and
professionals and I just wanted to throw
that out there um it's a side point but
you know and also would prevent
frivolous and you know retaliatory and
malicious um claims and accusations
being filed and then not being held
accountable because you know file uh
filing a false police report or um
committing perjury and an affidavit you
know those are crimes those can be held
accountable too in Criminal Court um so
I I just look at you
know you've got to bring them into a
court of record where the magistrate is
independent of the cause at hand meaning
they're not getting paid by the same
program as who brought the cause forward
they're um they're not uh a part of the
same agency that brought it Forward
right every they have to be impartial
the jury uh is chosen from their peers
you know all the facts are are um tested
by the jury and all of this is is
underpinned and and the court is moved
by common law in criminal court and in
Civil Court that's how it's supposed to
be but but these statutes have been
implemented that sidestep that and it's
all now in
void so it needs to be um it needs to be
completely redone and thrown away and
and and fixed um as far as you know
there's a maximum of law that says
prevention is better than cure there's a
lot of people have already been very
severely hurt by these unconstitutional
courts and the state of New Hampshire
might be liable in the future for what
occurred there if it's true that and and
I fully believe that it is that how it's
being done is not constitutional um so
we got to consider that and then the
very real harms to the families on both
sides because um if you have an
impartial tribunal that's actually
Judiciary with a real judge and jury um
you know it not only will it be more
difficult to um for someone's subjective
like gatekeeping to let a a real
harm get be gotten away with um but
either way you know what I mean
like it it also will prevent innocent
people from from being
prosecuted thank you that's uh been 10
minutes um I do want to read for
everybody um part first Article 15 no
subject shall be held to answer for any
crime or offense until the same is fully
and plainly substantially and formally
described to him or be compelled to
accuse or furnish EV evidence against
himself every subject shall have the
right to produce all proofs that may be
favorable to himself to meet the
witnesses against him face to face and
to be fully heard in his defense by
himself and counsel no subject shall be
arrested imprisoned despoiled or
deprived of his property immunities or
privileges put out of protection of the
law exiled or deprived of his life's
Liberty of estate but by the Judgment of
his peers or the law of the land
provided that in any proceeding to
commit a person acquitted of a criminal
charge by reason of insanity due process
shall require the clear and convincing
evidence that the person is potentially
dangerous to himself or to others and
that the person suffers from a mental
disorder must be established every
person held to answer in any other crime
or offense punishable by De deprivation
of Liberty shall have the right to
counsel at the expense of the state if
need is shown this right he is at
Liberty to wave but only after the
matter has been thoroughly explained by
the court uh so my question to you is um
in order to understand if that is being
done is it reasonable to find out the
policies and the procedures and the
intersection between everybody
involved um I think it's already been
presented that that the way DCF is doing
things and the way the legislature set
things up is um Incorrect and so now
we're all aware of it so whatever the
policies and procedures are um they're
kind of
secondary you just have to move forward
and start and just put everything
everything you know DCF needs to to get
um sworn affidavits and and bring it to
the court they know how to do that
they've done it you know I've read cases
where they did that um so respectfully I
think it's it's already been presented I
think that all the policies and
procedures will have to be redone later
in the perspective of keeping in line
with this um with with part one Article
15 and the rest of the
and I did I did just want to make if I
may Madam chair one more um there's one
other question willia gets you there
representative
Weber are you aware that every single
dcn DCF
case starts in court with a sworn
affidavit that's good but why doesn't it
stay there and then proceed to a trial
by jury that's where it goes wrong if
that's how it starts
then that's the accuser and then the
person has a right to face that accuser
under due process um I think the
committee needs to really understand
what um the what common law due process
is and common law is just those
fundamental principles they're the
maxims of law as an attorney I'm sure
you're very familiar with them the
established maximums they're basically
the the laws of Law and they're what um
judges Ed to help guide juries in in
finding fact and making decisions as
well as um the rulings of of Courts so
that all of that comes together to
provide what has been consistently and
through custom and usage over time shown
to be um fair and constitutional due
process so that's what I would say is is
from there they should be taking charges
you can't be soft on crime and then um
you know not you're on one side being
soft on crime by bringing it into a
quasi civil quasi criminal venue right
where they don't get a criminal penalty
um and you you're kind of stringing them
along for a year and a half or however
long with all these hearings and they
might get a chance and they go through
therapy and they do this and that um but
that's all Sid stepping you know if a
parent knows that if they hurt
someone that they're going to be
criminally charged that's quite a
disincentive it's quite an incentive to
uh you know be doing the right thing um
on top of
it so you're you're soft on crime on one
side in in those in those tribunals and
then in the in the family court and the
way it's done and then on the other side
we're saying well a lot of kids are left
to be harmed well I mean that's why it's
because the facts aren't being found the
the Constitutional way the founders were
very smart and and this um trial by jury
you know was consistently shown to be
like a just such a
foundational requirement of our form of
government and Society at at the
founding and going back to England thank
you uh follow up from representative
Weber and then representative Greg thank
you and I'm I'm reminding myself that
this is not the time to dialogue about
my beliefs versus your beliefs because
they are very different but my
and we will have that discussion in a
work session which is where it's
appropriate my second question to you is
are you aware of the fact that dcyf
proceedings are not criminal in nature
they are not held in the criminal court
and they are a different kind of
proceeding
entirely yes thank you they are
administrative tribunals and they are
unconstitutional thank you
representative Greg
I'm just curious and in what you posed
and um are saying is necessary for uh
somebody to be accused or have their
children taken
away I guess I'm missing the point where
the child's constitutional right comes
in as far as being able to be safe and
have their own rights do the parents
rights and their ability to go to court
and have this H whole jury trial
supersede any danger to the child like
because those are those are a process
you you have to pick a jury you have to
get lawyers like you're talking months
or years so how does that work in
protecting kids so it's kind of a trick
question um the child's rights are being
protected when someone puts in a sworn
affidavit seeking due process to get a
penalty for this child and get this
child safe so if that parent then is
arrested because of that evidence in the
form of a sworn affidavit they go to
jail their child goes to the next of kin
if they don't have next ofkin then
there's a place for this for DCF to come
in and get involved but I mean you
that's why we have bail that's why we
have preliminary hearings um there's
likely a constitutional way to keep a
child safe while the due process is
being carried out but that's why due
process also is supposed to be prompt
without delay you know you're supposed
to have a speedy trial we have all these
protections a follow up from
representative Greg yes thank you and by
the way thank you I forgot to thank you
earlier and thank you for taking our
questions and for being here so in this
um didn't like lose my turn of thought
uh the problem is when you're
investigating something and I don't know
if you heard me earlier that what one
person might think is abuse another
person sees as um well I'm just child
rearing this is my right to knock my kid
into next week if they're not behaving
or whatever so so there has to be an
investigation done so you wouldn't rest
arrest somebody before an investigation
is done and I think that's what the
process is now how would that work
because you don't want to just arrest
everybody that gets accused without
proper I would think that would be more
offensive to their rights of just being
arrested when we're trying to do an
investigation so where's that balance on
that um well I guess that's a good
question but it's uh kind of a
misunderstanding about how criminal
investigations are done usually people
are arrested when they have preliminary
evidence and that that uh affidavit
would provide that the jurisdiction for
the court to then issue a warrant for
that person to be arrested and then any
attempt to um you know before or during
the the arrest or after it interfere
with the ability for the investigation
to be carried out um that would be
problematic problematic for the person
who is trying to stop that um and anyway
in the interim the child either the
parent would be in
jail awaiting trial um or they would be
out on bail and likely would have
preliminary orders from a judge that
child thank you very much for coming and
sharing with us I hope you stay involved
thank you um traditionally um we will
hear Representatives first my question
though representative Horgan do you have
other committee business because we had
a few come in before
you if you don't if you wouldn't
okay I will set a two-minute timer and
hold you to that is that all right
representative
microphone so I'm representing Timothy
Horan from straford County District 10
the town of Durham and um you don't
really have an enviable job ahead of me
I was part of a similar initiative
um well back my second term which was a
long time ago 2011 to 2012 the petitions
and redress committee and that's why I
put in the pink card because resent
quman referred to that El of the
Constitution and we ran into many guess
many many problems one was you know it
wasn't clear what our procedures were
which I guess uh it's a little bit
clearer for for your group but also um
we mostly dealt with similar disputes
and also people about DCF which
certainly is not perfect but
um we often hear from only one parent
when there's another parent and other
family members involved so the f is
families and also we have children and
youth so the children are human beings
their own right and have their own have
their own concerns um which often um get
lost in the shuffle so and that's uh one
thing to keep in mind also people often
tend to do do data dumps on it which I
think I looks like that's happening
today where they provide a voluminous
amount of amount of material which um
may or may not support the conclusion
that respected the draw from is just
there's a huge stack of paper doesn't
necessarily mean that what's being said
is is is is accurate and we um we didn't
put people under oath either that's a
wise decision on your part not to Madam
chair but um people would often
certainly submit affidavits and those
affidavits first of all sometimes even
the facts that people swear to an
affidavits are false and often the
material they put in the affidavit is
not really factual either it's just our
conclusions about the law and that's uh
just because you put an affidavit and
then may put a bunch of gassy prologues
on it doesn't necessarily mean that that
document is of of any relevance so
that's something else to keep in contact
with and also something we struggled
with and was just sort of the
confidentiality of the data because
people often submit you know very um
personal information which maybe is not
necessarily appropriate to be passing
around in an open house committee proced
seing so um anyway good luck you you
won't be able to sort this out before
the end of the session but maybe you can
make a little bit of progress so thanks
that's what I wanted to say basically
thank you very much representative orgon
I I realized we have a challenge in
front of us and you were just about on
you yes um next we have Robert leontin
um I had already had you next in the
stack um I do see that you're from
Vermont in the future I think think
we'll probably be limiting testimony to
people from New Hampshire since this is
New Hampshire DCF unless they've had
involvement with New Hampshire DCF but U
Mr lontine um you've asked for 10
minutes so I'll have my little timer let
you know when you're there so then you
you thank you very much for listening to
me my name is Robert
lontine I'm originally from New
Hampshire I was born in nton in
1964 I left New Hampshire because I got
strong armed out of this state because
of the state laws that they
created back in
1988 I was ambushed into a child
endangerment crime three
counts um
I uh went to trial I didn't take a plea
deal the then County
attorney uh never turned over
exculpatory evidence in my trial and put
a known detective on the stand that had
credibility issues five
years before I was ever charged or
convicted of
anything I didn't find this out until
over 40 years
later I went to prison in this town for
my children are
gone they were they're just gone I don't
we don't talk you know this whole I was
poisoned by the Department of Child
Welfare I was poisoned by the family
court
system
and Not only was I poisoned but I was
both physically and mentally and
things it's hard for me to come up here
and talk with a bunch of strangers that
I don't even know about what I went
through I can imagine all the other
thousands and thousands of people that
are out there that have been in the same
position as I am that are not strong
enough to come up here and throw a
backbone and tell the public about
what's going
on
I don't know what else to say other than
the fact that I'm not going to stop if I
got to keep coming to these hearings
once a month and testify against you
guys I
will but something has to be done about
this if we let the people that did test
through all of us get away with this
then you
give Joe and Jane public the etern of
right to do the same damn thing to any
one of
them that's all I got to
say Thank you Mr lontine I'm so sorry
for everything that you went through and
that your family went through with this
um specifically it sounds like making
sure that all evidence is presented in a
timely way and that thing a trial is
Speedy though with those two things that
um would be important to address in
order to make you realiz make make you
understand that we're trying to make
sure that nobody else has to go through
a situation like that I don't know what
to believe anymore I just don't
know thank you it's got to be hard
representative
Weber I I was also going to ask as a
followup both to your testimony and
representative Leon's question is is it
of any um help to you in your quest to
know that since the time when all of
this happened to you we have now made
significant strides and people are
working now and going forward on
ensuring issues of credibility of the
members of the police force that come
and testify and that they are are no
longer protected when they have
complaints Bas to believe okay okay
because I've been lied to have been
taking ADV very poisoned me against my
own
kids and I know there's no way to make
up for that oh I know that there is no
way to make up for it but how do you
expect me to trust anybody in this room
when I've been betrayed so
badly we can't we can't ask that of you
but thank you for coming up with and
sharing this for with us I thank
sorry um next I'd like to call Robert
tangue I believe um you gave us 10
minutes and I will set the timer for 10
minutes I'll bring it up to this if it
gets to there so that you can just
conclude your statements at that point
thank
you
turned it
off it always gets me um thank you so
much everybody my name is Robert tangue
I've uh spoken before the special
committee and um having a lot of
problems with the family courts um and
also DCF uh I'm going to start out going
wide then I'm going to get specific and
then I'm going to get uh wide again
maybe make some
recommendations uh I appreciate you all
really trying
to solve
this it's not an easy situation um what
I passed out to the committee is to show
what's really going on as I wrote a
letter which is a guide but then on the
back is fraud that's been spread at the
governor's office uh sorry defamation
office I swear everything I'm saying is
the best to the my knowledge so help me
God because God does exist God is nature
it's the foundation of our
Constitution which was created prior to
the US Constitution four years prior and
afterwards we got our Fourth Amendment
protections the Constitution protects us
from the government which the government
is just people and people always do
what's in their best perceived interest
they're always going to do what they
feel is right
Justified and then we have laws we have
constitutions um as as speaking uh prior
uh someone uh I think it was rep Greg
was talking about the child's rights and
if you read the the Constitution if
youve ever been despoiled of anything
you read the Constitution it will make
You Weep
because it was done to protect us
article two natural rights all men have
certain natural essential and inherent
rights among which are the enjoying and
defending of life liberty acquiring
possessing and protecting property and
in a word seeking and obtaining
happiness now I want to bring back to
property
because the uh the family unit women and
children used to be considered property
in Constitution they and and you might
say that that's a horrible thing but
they did they still don't have to
register for Selective Service women
should be able to vote women should be
able to do everything men can do um
based on your own
abilities but this property the family
unit the courts are not looking at this
appropriately
we have a family when a person breaks up
a family that is abuse on a child that
hurts a child and take it from someone
who's never had a
father but the guy who was a father
was killed in a truck
accident
and I grew up very
hurt the reason why I'm here is because
I've gone to everybody else else if
you'll see on that piece of paper I've
been to the governor's office the
Attorney General the mayor of Manchester
DHHS DCF the Manchester conquered and
Windham police the family courts lawyers
judges Bar Association New Hampshire
legal aid which by the way their website
doesn't even work they get federal and
state grant money their website doesn't
even work I make websites for a living I
could fix it in days it's
misappropriation of money I'm not angry
at any of you I'm just being
passionate about what's going on because
these people are getting hundreds of
millions of dollars dcyf the family
courts judges lawyers
to pretend like they know what exactly
what is right or wrong I've gone to the
special committee for the family courts
the house Speaker asked for more time
been to the New Hampshire Coalition for
domestic
violence I believe that they're the ones
who put this propaganda it says in this
letter that I was
ordered to have a mental evaluation or I
would have to have supervised visits and
I refused
it that's not true I was never
ordered mental evaluation I was
never ordered supervisor the lawyer
didn't even opposing counsel didn't even
ask for that so I'm being human
trafficked and so are my children and
I've reported it to the Manchester
police they hung up on
911 that's after the Attorney General
told me in writing if I feel my children
are being abused I'm sorry not the
Attorney General uh YZ so Deputy that if
I feel like I'm being abused call
911 so I eventually did after calling
the Manchester police so you guys are
talking about bringing these Chiefs of
police here they're all in on it now not
to say that the police do what is
most of the stuff that they do is very
good but there's an inherent bias and
that bias is to protect women and
children and
women get all the protections under the
law unless and I've talked to a lot of
families the Father the man is more
politically connected so what we're
having is a system of Judges
lawyers
administrators Department department
heads all appointed by the
governor Supreme Court justice as well
and Governor sununu is not a good
Governor I've been reaching out to him
for over a year in
writing he has a lawyer Rudy who won't
give me this I caught it on video and I
know what it says he won't give it
they're just playing games they don't
really want to help their children so
when we get to the family courts and
we're looking at everything is decided
by the courts everything anyone in here
can be accused of anything or say that
someone's violating
me they can be the the police get to
choose who to investigate who to
prosecute the judges decide whatever
they want and in my specific case they
ordered and then reaffirm the order
physically and mathematically impossible
findings of fact physically and
mathematically impossible findings of
fact that's fraud they know about it
based on the evidence that they received
the lawyer knows about it the lawyer has
a duty to report this to the judge the
judge knows about it signed affidavits
they hide it because the first thing the
police do when you go to them is you say
they they say do you have a lawyer this
is the way it needs to
go if a child is being abused you go to
the the police the police unlike in
harmony Montgomery's case make an arrest
if there's probable cause and that's
what we're all
forgetting at the end of all this is the
Manchester
police and their inherent bias because
they have a contract out which I will
get to you guys I was trying to find
that right now but I can't find it um
but it was a contract signed to only
train to train prosecutors judges police
only to protect women only and then the
grant was given to someone on the
domestic violence task force which
effectually is a pay raise of TW a 25%
pay raise for
$55,000 I can say this because I have
the contracts signed by Diane Martin on
November 30th 2022 which was the same
day that a fictitious domestic violence
petition was put against me so some of
the specifics and I know that it's a lot
and I do appreciate what you said uh
Madam chair about there's only so much
we can handle we need a jury trial in
can have settle Family Matters in the
family courts if the judges aren't lying
the judges are lying because it's called
an expedited child support uh and I
really appreciate uh there's a contract
for it with the AOC so I really
appreciate what you what you guys are
doing and I understand that it's a lot I
call
dcyf 633 col 7 is human trafficking part
three of it is abuse by abuse of the
legal process I would say
fraud I would say that uh ordering me to
violate a protection order and then
holding me in contempt for not violating
ating that protection order after I gave
the judges and courts over and over
here's 173b here's what you have to do
which is the protection order we need to
start repealing laws we need to start
which 173b is unconstitutional it's at
the Supreme Court right now I'm arguing
that it's unconstitutional via Article
15 article 14 is the protection of
access to Justice no denial of Justice
no cost all our laws that you create and
that we uphold are all based upon the
Constitution and it all makes sense you
can't kill anybody you can't attack
anybody only in
self-defense
so the end there's two things that this
committee can do if you can just wrap up
with it it sounds like you are thank you
there's two things this committee can do
it can record this testimony which it's
doing
now and that be a message work with the
the individual agencies including the
this and if they don't correct their
behavior the legislature has a
constitutional power and
duty to remove these
justices and I think it's getting very
close to the point where when judges are
lying and writing fraud and then hiding
and abusing the legal process that
that's at this point I'd hope that
anybody has any questions I know I was
kind of a little all over the place but
I would appreciate any questions if you
do have thank you very much for your
testimony than you are there any
questions um no thank you thank you very
much for your testimony um I hope that
you saw that when we're going to be
looking for this we want to make sure
that things are handled appropriately
moving between different groups so that
if anything's been dropped in the
process that um we can solve those
problems okay so thank you um so then I
I do want make it very fair note okay so
this is a picture of criminal defamation
at the governor's office this group and
the legislators have a a duty and a
power to
impeach the governor and then here's all
the other things so I will be giving you
the specific names such as judge previt
um say if you want to give that to us in
writing I need to make I need to
understand exactly what it is that
you're asking and um testimony and I I
have absolutely no problem saying these
names because I know 100% that the
record provides it thank you so much I
you next we have Katrina
Hinrich you said three minutes is that
three minutes solid
or okay perfect I'll let you know when
it's there so that uh then you can wrap
you
don't
everybody um I was going to start off
with something part of my DCF experience
but I wanted to uh touch real quick and
this might cause my three minute issue
um Mr tangway brought up a point and and
it it has some Merit and I think it's
something you guys should look
into so when judges are writing orders
because of or I should say Family Court
judges there is an opinion that they're
writing now that's from our own Supreme
Court they wrote an opinion of what a
marital Master referee can
do they can write an opinion it is not
an enforcable
order the
state then put on the caveat that
a official judge in other words an
officer of the state could sign off and
basically rubber stamp it the caveat is
they are not
to put too much time into into reading
it because they they claim their lack of
resources and and I totally believe it
time is a
resource but once that gets signed or
stamped that order now becomes real it's
not real when it's written but then it
becomes very real and at that point if
there's falseness in it it becomes a
lialis order which is something that I
have personally experienced so that is
my understanding of the way that
works um with that said I will move on
with the DCF piece and I'm going to give
you a little
clarification dcy have got involved in
my case because there was an assault on
my oldest child by the other parent um
something unfortunately I had to witness
something she had to experience and then
I wound up experiencing also my forms of
abuse off of
it with that
said dcyf did not get immediately
involved but we did get pushed there it
mechanism my biggest Focus as a mom at
that point and you guys can understand
me was the health and well-being of my
daughter I could care less about what
the other person did I could care less
about the arrest that just happened down
the road as the person runs
away um what I cared about was my
daughter
and I knew at this point I'd already
experienced enough to know that things
were getting very bad my goal was to get
out and I did speak to you guys last
week about this I got divorced got out
immediately found myself pulled right
back in on motions of we're going to
change
things well okay make something do do
something make make that little
Amendment whatever you got to do let's
move on 10 years in court is not just a
little Amendment or a little change
that is when I started digging into what
is the motivations behind some of
this right back up into it another DCF
event happened DCF chose not to get
involved but again it looked really
really bad on the other person and this
was because the hospital a local
hospital called the police two nights in
a row for me to come and get my children
one of them was trying to be admitted on
psychiatric
evaluations but the police actually
called was called by the hospital on the
other parent it wasn't the
child when I went in to get the children
the police officers told me look this is
the second night in the row you really
really need to come and get these kids
and get a get a restraining order and
stuff I said I've tried that but I need
reports be at the police station 9:00 I
get there I met at the window the
administrator tells me chief police says
there's not going to be any
reports
okay when we actually get the log the
police log the police log was false it
actually says two nights in a row Kyle
called juvenile delinquent it was never
a call on the child it was a call on the
other parents so that that's false it's
absolutely
false with that said I got pushed right
over into as you already know family
court and what I started noticing was
there had to be reason this was
happening
so having a financial back yep just up
to that um I'll give you another two
minutes to wrap it out yep I just got
into the financial part of it I had to
start looking at what was really truly
going on and that led me to title
four and as far as I'm concerned all the
research I've done over the past like 10
to 12 years title 4 is the Catalyst to
what is running the family court we know
that the
gets large amounts of money from them we
also know that if you read through title
4 and I'll give you I'll give you the
actual piece so you guys have it
incentive payments to the states under
Section
458 of us Code
658a that is incentive payments and this
four with that
piece um there's also some consent
issues that need to be addressed in
title 4 that is not
happening one of the pieces that is
relevant is the Judiciary salary like a
judge an officer of the state cannot be
paid cannot be paid out of title for
money but marital Masters and referees
can which then bring you to how the
state has set up the family court
organization it is completely ran with
an we'll say an a loose oversight of the
judicial branch by private
contractors referees are private
contractors marital Masters are private
contractors G's are private contractors
therapists are private
contractors attorneys technically
private contractors the list goes on so
the organization itself seems to be very
structured as a business entity which
according to what I've read about the
way the state structured it that's
exactly what they intended to do it is
privately ran and I'm Unsure how we get
due process rights when it's ran by
private citizens and there's no no
oversight so that's kind of where I'm
I'm at with the title four it's it
money thank you very much um and thank
you for that tie into the due process um
is there any questions from anybody
thank you so much I appreciate you
us
see so now I have three other cards um
one's for seven minutes one's for 10
minutes one's for 30 to 40 minutes um I
Mr noon um would you mind limiting it to
10 minutes or otherwise I'm going to put
you at the end of the stack just to
time
okay there there will be more in the
future so if you can limit it to one
topic so that we don't get overwhelmed
and talk to us just about one part of
that that would help us a
lot we'll we'll do thank you um Don
Donald
Gilbert thank you I have you down for
seven
minutes good morning thank you madam
chair uh many of you in this room know
who I am what most of my testimonies are
about many of you have received emails
in depth about many of these t four
issues
um it's really something that we need to
take more serious and there's a reason
why we're all here
today um it's not just a
misappropriation of funds but it is a
gross neglect on behalf of our state uh
and the federal government is cracking
down uh it is not a question of if it is
a question of when uh child support is a
big aspect of that um that ties into all
of this that some of these members have
received emails
on uh while everybody's focusing on more
on the due process side of the parents I
take a different approach and do focus
on the due process side of the children
as well and while a lot of people will
disagree or agree with my positionings
on it I do feel that if we were
following the protocols the polic IES
and the laws on the books today we would
not be abusing the due process of the
parents children and all parties
involved that being said that is not
occurring um it's just outright not um
speaking to a point that representative
Weber said uh said
that um all of these DCF cases start in
court that is absolutely unfactual uh
these cases do not start in court um
mostly the time they are being closed
out as founded problem resolved so that
they can procure criminal charges
because if you look at the Statue of 169
C and the criminal prosecution of any of
these entities or issues you cannot
criminally charge somebody there's a
under 169c uh 12a I believe there is use
immunity for any person that's involved
with
dcyf for criminal conviction you are not
allowed to charge anybody for a criminal
crime that is involved with DCF in a
court
case that is upheld by Melissa M uh 127
710 in New Hampshire Supreme Court from
1986 where they ruled that use immunity
uh for individuals involved with dcyf
are immune from Criminal liability
um could you give us that citation again
please I can Melissa M 7 uh
710 yep not a problem so again these are
some of these issues that are going on
is where you have that use immunity
involved but then you have DCF Casa and
unfortunately even a child's attorney at
this current time trying to procure
criminal charges for a parent that's
involved with
dcyf um I'm not going to get into too
much specifics but this case has been
going on for four years now and some of
these members have heard recently that
the child has been asking to appear in
court for three years now with dcyf and
Casa refusing the child to
appear and that that's a due process
violation of the child's rights the
child has every right the child is now
second and we have every party denying
this child from having the voice that
they deserve and I understand that I'm
you know potentially the accused party
I'm not the only party of this case
there's multiple parties uh there's 10
children involved uh only one of them is
my mom my own um which you can see the
gravity of the situation based on
that um
sorry
um yeah so we have this situation where
we're denying these children's rights to
their voice in their day in court when
they're
requesting their day in court and I
understand obviously yes it it's hard it
nobody's saying that it's easy to have
that child come into court and here
what's being said the gruesome acts that
are going on to multiple children not
biologic to myself that are biologic to
the
child but it's something that had we
have followed the policies and
procedures from day one none of this
would have happened we're sitting on an
issue where the Attorney General stepped
in in November uh and indeed uh alleged
that well confirmed the allegations
presented by multiple parties that DCF
was perjuring themselves with regards to
Fitness and uh some other
issues um against DCF uh DCF has not
been factual in nature the entirety of
the case load and it has presented
serious harm to multiple
children uh with an episode of in last
year which I testified before the family
and child law committee about this
earlier this year that there was an
episode last summer where some of these
children were exposed to adult sexual
activity with the child present in the
bed and DCF still left that child inside
that
home so these are some of the arous
issues
and these are not exclusive to my family
um these are not exclusive to any one
family we I have I can't give that
information obviously because I'm not at
Liberty to go ahead and you know inflict
potential retaliation against other
families but we have multiple families
that are presenting uh similar to the
Dennis Von Jr case where parents are
making these reports of concerns against
these workers not following laws and
procedures and it's turning out to be
detrimental to these children
I think that's where I'll leave that for
today um as many of you know that I'll
be back around sooner
enough thank you and I'm sorry that
you've been through this process
um I'm not sure if there's any questions
um but thank you and you actually were
exactly seven minutes I paused it for 30
seconds while you while I was giving you
time to compose yourself I don't think
anybody can do that yeah but thank you
and um hopefully we can find those
any gaps in policies and procedures
because um we need to have standards so
that things can be done correctly so
thank you thank you madam
chair um next I'd like to call Shelby
Boyce um you'd said 10 minutes at least
um so you've probably missed it when we
first were introducing this um we just
need to make sure that what we have is
something that we can that we can manage
with what you have if there's if it gets
to go too long it's harder for us to get
the value of everything you're saying
and we might lose something important
that you've shared with us um so I'm
going to set the timer for 10 minutes
I'll let you just wrap up at that point
but if you can try and keep just to the
details that we need and not share
anything that's too personal that you
don't want to have on this recorded
testimony with um YouTube so with that
thank you thank you um for letting me
speak I haven't really had a voice for
um the past like five years um I've been
dealing with DCF and actually a lot of
people and I don't really know how to
sum this up and I'm kind of just
swinging it um I have four disabled
children
and a um felon was pushed into my life
where I started a relationship and we
moved to lonia and when we got there
abuse started happening pretty bad and
it wasn't just abuse from the partner
that I was with it was the cops the
school abusing my son locking him in the
Huts he's nonverbal like a lot of
traumatic things started
happening my daughter you know got
abused by his son and they didn't have
enough information
apparently and you know off that goes
they accused my ex-husband of touching
my children and then tried to put my
kids with him in fact they did for a
brief moment there's a there's too much
in my case that I don't know how to
focus on one thing because nobody's
listened it's absolutely disgusting that
you you accuse a man of touching his
children then you never investigate him
he flees to Texas then he comes back and
now you're trying to reunify my children
with him
because I'm in an abusive relationship
over one
report there's a lot of proof in this
case and everything that I had they
literally just took it away they made me
lose my apartment by taking my partner
and giving him a 30-day stepback over
one incident that they didn't have
really any proof of they didn't give him
a chance to do anything they just came
in with no contacts on everything the
dcyf worker came and brought me boxes
every day in court that we were there I
would cry my eyes out and I'm like you
take my partner away and I'm going to be
homeless I can't get my kids back if I'm
homeless I'm just a a single mom
basically of four disabled children
living off of $1,500 a month they gave
him I know I'm kind of all over the
place cuz it's hard it's hard for me
I've been through some serious trauma in
the situation between all of these
people I've been sex trafficked I have
dealt with horrendous things since
losing my apartment and I don't know how
to how to say it to anybody but nobody
has listened this whole time um DCF just
makes false
reports it's absolutely disgusting they
hide the facts you know the day I moved
in there was there was
um them telling me that I couldn't let
my ex-husband around the kids but and to
change the order at the court and you
know I did what they told me to do and I
I can't even think right now I'm like
sorry I'm sorry is it the sorry if you
take a breath I can't I didn't this is
kind of like a last minute thing and I
I'm not good at speaking and I don't
know what I'm supposed to say and not
say and Pa just one second it seems to
me that it's a lack of it's a lack of
consistency would you say that it's a
lack of consistency from them lack of
consistency they literally build up
cases that just don't make any sense and
there's so much chaos and you they give
you a partial discovery of you know a
banker's box and it's all scattered it's
not even in order it things are missing
they don't take any evidence from you
you know you have everything and they
just hide it all it it's too many people
involved and too much abuse going on and
you know
I thank you I don't know how to deal
with this this this is disgusting what
they're doing to families they have
traumatized my kids they put them in VPI
they put them in National Children's
Home they've been bouncing them all
around they put things in their head you
know now my daughter wants thinks she's
a boy and my non-verbal Sons at Easter
Seals like permanently like they
separated at all of us and just abused
Us in so many ways and I can't I have so
a trauma and my brain doesn't work right
from it um you're you're doing a amazing
job getting no you are you've been
through a really really difficult
situation not enough time to sit there
and explain everything that's happened
in years is it all right if we just ask
you a couple of these questions or so
that this this can be focused a little
to help you out we're trying to help you
by asking you I understand okay
representative Weber you had a question
I just had a clarifying question so I
would understand what you said already
and if this is inappropriate or tough
for you you it's fine not to answer um
at one point you used the word partner
and at one point I you used the word
husband am I thinking that the husband
is an ex-husband and the partner is your
current partner I have an ex-husband if
that's difficult I have an ex-husband
and then I had divorced him he was
abusive and and this guy from conquered
prison was pushed on
me um
so different people and I'm not with
this person it's been two years now okay
um that person introduced me to
drugs I was being
drugged I was being psychologically just
tormented by
him by by everybody in
lonia and I just being messed with the
whole
time and I'm so sorry and I don't I
don't want you to go deeper into
anything you don't want to go into I
just I don't mind going into anything
I'm just afraid I don't know what I'm
supposed to say or not say because I've
been told that I need to basically be
quiet I've been threatened my life has
been threatened severely this whole time
and then they didn't understand why I
wouldn't leave my
partner and and get help and they
weren't helping me and and I was scared
I mean I was literally being
drugged I would wake up with nle marks
in my arms and petrify the needles I
don't do that nobody listens so if I can
just interrupt you now you have shared
so much with us and I'm so sorry with
everything you've gone through how do
you come at somebody they came at me
because of my spiritual beliefs because
I had a near death experience that was
really really traumatic and they made me
they forced me to go and have a
emergency mental health evaluation
without a warrant would not leave my
house that if I didn't go do it wave my
Hippa and tell them everything about
this spiritual awakening that was mocked
that they were going to take my kids
from
school they've done so many things
funny I you're so brave for coming and
sharing this with us I if if I can I'm
just going to ask probably makes sense
to end what you're saying now but I'd
love to talk with you more it's so hard
to come and talk in front of people like
this yeah it is and you're doing an
amazing job um I know we all feel for
you with what you've gone through with
us I don't think and of you could ever
feel what we go through I don't believe
that for a second you cannot feel
somebody else's pain unless you have
walked down that path yourself that is a
fact and you have these workers who are
not trained who are young who have have
no life experience no children don't
have a clue about anything their
perception is so not there they're
bias they there's stigma there's so much
and they don't listen to a damn thing
you
say they just abuse you more if you if
you say your rights if you say what's
the truth you just get
abused thank you um there's people on
here that have had life experiences that
give them a lot ofion to you sure but I
just I don't think it' be going on if
you guys really knew I don't know how
you can let it
happen what we're here thank you we're
we're here we're here to try and stop
that from happening thank you oh sorry
representative uh love you have a
question for what was your name
you hold on I'm gonna just take a five
yeah
e
um thank you for that Indulgence I'm
going to open um this meeting back up
again this is such an emotional topic
and it's so important that we just
wanted to make sure that we were able to
um just make sure that people understand
just how much the testimony means to us
um with that um I will call uh Mr Joseph
uh noon up to this up to speak um and
I'll let you know when you're at 10
minutes because if you're able to get us
down into something um that we can
process at this one I know that you'll
be back in other ones as well if you
could let me know to 10 minutes and then
give me a two-minute wrap up that'd be
wonderful I will um thank you I Joseph
noon do solemly swear to tell the whole
truth and nothing but the truth so help
me
God this is really hard to wrap up in 10
minutes I'm going to kind of just uh go
off the cuff here
uh back in March of
2022 uh and a um my wife went to run
some errands and allowed our then
twoyear old daughter who had just fallen
asleep after being at a playground uh in
conquer to ride her bike because there
was no bike riding in Haner where we
live because it's was March uh she
allowed our daughter to take a nap while
she ran into a store to make a quick
return came back about 20 minutes later
and there was police outside her car
they had a little talk there was no um
uh citations issued and my wife went
home a few days later we get a call from
uh Melissa kums social worker at DCF
hi I'm Melissa I'm from the
state I said Melissa I reject your offer
to contract with me and then I promptly
sent a cease and assist order with a fee
schedule to the director of uh DCF at
that time Joseph RIS bomb and in that
ceas and
assist I put all of the reasons or not
all but some of the reasons why I did
not why I rejected DC F's offer to
contract with me these guys are offering
to contract with people and they're
using quite literally uh threats of
violence threats of getting the police
and courts involved they're calling
Family Court a court it's not a court
it's a legislative tribunal wasn't
created by the Judiciary it doesn't
exercise due process of law so they're
using all of these elements and weapons
quite regularly
to uh sort of threatening Cor people
into Contracting with them by accepting
their services by accepting their offers
um and they don't even know what's
happening because well let's be you know
blunt here uh America has been really
dumbed down the entire Western world has
been dumbed down the vocabulary of
somebody 100 years ago that was on this
dirt here in New Hampshire was much
greater the intelligence was much
greater 100 years ago for for the
average whoever than it is today so
people don't even know what's going on
and they're being
deceived uh I also uh in my cease and
desist order which I'm going to give a
copy to you guys I just did a real
simple thing you guys want to see how
horrible New Hampshire dcyf is follow
the money do an internet search NH dcyf
settlements and I hope you have a strong
stomach because you can't even re go
through all the Articles if you love
children and care about our posterity uh
with you know just being brought to
tears or being made sick when you start
reading about the settlements hundreds
of millions of dollars have been paid
out just in New Hampshire alone to
settle cases against
dcyf time and time and time again now uh
I don't know if you guys uh I'm going to
read a little bit for my affidavit here
that was permitted permitted to this uh
that was submitted to this
committee uh the social workers are
lying all the time yeah they sign these
uh affidavits under oath of penalty and
perjury and put lies right into him oh
another thing is I did a write to no
request for the oath of office of the
director of DCF for the oath of office
of Melissa kums a social worker I got a
letter back that said I'll find it here
in a second that they don't have any
oath of office there is no oath to the
Constitution how are these people even
supposed to understand what processes if
they have no oath of office the police
officers have an oath of office the
Haner PD I asked them for their oath
oath of office for all their officers
and they give it to me it's there it
exists I get a denial I also asked them
about their bonding information all
government agents all governmental
agents all Municipal corporate employees
DCF actually is probably not even part
of the government best best I can tell
it's a mere Municipal Corporation it's
all it is and you guys or the
legislature funds it the legislature
makes it
exist because you guys fund it because
it exists by the legislature and I don't
mean just you individuals in this room
but the legislature in general you have
the ability to look at every single
document all of the funding uh all these
sealed cases should be able to be
unsealed and looked into by the
legislature maybe there you guys haven't
figured out how to do that but if you
control them and you allow them exist
you the legislature gave them life the
legislature can take all away from dcyf
I believe and that should be happening
so in an affidavit which is from this
motion to enter which is what the social
workers the first pleading that they
give to Family
Court uh Melissa kums social worker lied
under oath in affidavit to of order to
to enter premise she
writes that um cpsw Melissa kums made
contact with hener Police Department who
stated they are familiar with the family
due to the residents being free Staters
anti-government and the family lives on
a compound with Lookouts henker police
States it's a dangerous situation and
will not go to the home without a court
order this is paragraph eight of the
right to enter that was filed and
submitted and signed under oath of
office I'm sorry signed under oath and
perjury henker Place police rebut the
claim affirmed by Melissa kums in in in
uh the police off narrative and in
affidavit he writes no one calls for
using the term anti-government Lookouts
dangerous or
compound
also uh social worker Melissa kums
subscribes various negative opinions
about my family property community and
lifestyle in an attempt to engender fear
amongst the family court and local law
enforcement and has caused irreparable
harm to my reputation and has caused
trespass of my property and has also
caused me hundreds of hours of time and
I have young children right now that are
two and four years old and if you're
parents you understand at the most
valuable time in your child's life is
within that first six-year window to
spend the maximum part of time the
maximum amount of time you can with them
um uh so another thing uh that these
guys started to talk about other people
in committee here uh testifying that
there's this financial incentive for uh
DCF and family rep to get money from the
federal government Social Security
Administration title four so there is a
Granite State College as part of the
Child Welfare education partnership
offers a class titled DCF Revenue
enhancements and RMS that is available
to social workers to maximize revenue
for DCF here's a quote this Workshop
right from their website this Workshop
will provide crucial information
regarding the various Federal funding
sources and how to access these sources
in in order to provide services to
Children and Families staff will learn
about various Federal funding sources to
title 4A title 4E and Medicaid for both
services and administration document
requirements for accessing federal funds
will be
discussed they're literally hunting for
this Federal fund money so this
assessment where she lies and says that
you know I'm dangerous and you know I'm
anti-government and that the police said
it which the police never
said uh was a whole another issue it in
this document it
orders that the police or a child
service worker may enter the premises
and interview a 2-year-old child
alone well if you internet search New
Hampshire DCF settlements you would be a
fool to allow dcyf to enter your house
and or interview your child alone so
that being
said uh the uh says the police officer
shall do it I went ahead with the local
henker chief of police and I said hey
you guys Matt fren is his name I said
Matt you and your Lieutenant Michelle
who happens to be a former social worker
and who is um also trained in child sex
crimes and you know things like that but
she's a mom that's what's important to
me she's a family woman uh Matt French
who is a family man a father uh and
they're both still with their you know
significant others the fathers of their
children I said you guys can do this
assessment that's fine they said great
when he emailed back to the lawyers at
at DCF hey uh the noes have agreed to um
you know police uh conducting this
assessment uh they said no you can't do
that even though the order says it also
Matt French reported very soon right
after he met me when he reached out to
me contacted me to meet with him uh the
very first moment I had available to
meet with him I said we're going down to
the Pancake House come meet us there so
me my wife and my two cat kids went to
the Pancake House to meet Matt French
and we when we chatted for an hour and a
half and at that day he reported I
believe that was March 29th he reported
the dcyf that there is no neglect or
abuse and that the children are fine
after that Matt French came to my
property multiple times no less than a
dozen times within the next 6 to 8 weeks
maybe 10 to 12 weeks actually it's it's
a wide period he came my property very
often and uh he talked to me he talked
to me about dcyf um this you know all
kinds of things I have a whole um
narrative from him I have an affidavit
he filed so we're at the 10 if you want
to wrap up for us DCF after being told
that there's no abuse or neglect after
being told that the the hener police
could do the assessment order rejected
all of that they said that the police
were incompetent they weren't able to do
this and then they escalated and they
went forth and Ross McLoud submitted a
motion to v a motion to um a contempt
motion against my wife and I in Family
Court I have here a verified expedited
motion to correct a record and change
the core order based on prior material
me misrepresentation that you guys
should absolutely read these are the
words of the hener chief of police uh
that motion was
vacated and here's the thing with the
assessment order it is orders the police
or a social worker to do something it
doesn't order a parent to do anything
Ross McLoud is very aware of this Jr
Hall a representative in this house made
Ross McLoud very aware of this with his
attorney in filings a year before um
they did this with me and so Ross McLoud
is just submitting garbage essentially
maladministration and fraud to these
family courts by submitting uh contempt
motion when the contempor is not even
named in an
order and we had hener police on board
to do this and the reason
dcyf as far as I'm concerned and best I
can tell did not want hener police doing
the assessment is because DCF gets paid
out of this title 4 program to do these
assessments each time they do an
assessment I heard the number is like
$6,000 to do an assessment you guys
should really look into this program to
uh maximize res revenue for DCF to
understand what the social workers are
being taught on how to maximize Revenue
this is a textbook definition of child
trafficking trafficking means buying
selling or trading transporting for
higher and we all know what children are
they're these little babies that we love
and there's demonic forces out there
that want to harvest their energy it's
been the tale that's been going on for
thousands of years books and movies are
written about this so I'll be back I'm
gonna um go back here and I'm going to
organize some papers for you guys to
read and I really want you to do
something about it because if good men
do nothing evil will
prevail and if nonviolent means do not
work Society breaks down to violence and
we don't want to go
there thank you very much for your
questions oh yes representative long
thank you thank you madam chair the uh
what was this what was was the school
course Granite State College gr State
College as part of child welfare
education
partnership and the title of the course
is the quote is
DCF Revenue enhancement and
RMS be sure to check out RMS that's a
whole Federal program to give money
representative cofal and then
representative
love thank you madam chair and thank you
for taking my question so at one point
you in your testimony you said that that
motion was vacated yes I I just want to
be clear was that was that the motion
for contempt or was that the motion that
you filed in response to I didn't file
any motion this this was this is uh the
motion for contempt was vacated by the
hener police department okay or or was
vacated by Family Court and it was filed
by the hker police
Department I I'm going to give that for
you guys to read so the so the hener
police department filed the mo the
motion to vacate the the contempt order
yes got it thank you representative love
can you clarify who is Ross McLoud Ross
McLoud is a attorney for New Hampshire
DCF um and he is actually paid out of I
believe the uh judicial uh budgeting
he's not paid out of dcyf or or Health
and Human
Services he's also a board of selectman
at
Windam sorry other questions um I have
one um it sounded you said that there
was discrepancies between what uh the
case worker um wrote down the police
saying and what the police said that
they did were do you know if those were
verbal Communications or written
Communications I have no idea uh between
the police department
basically in the document which that
particular document I forgot to bring
the um uh assessment order I I have a I
have it on the computer here but it
basically says henker police States is
what the document says I haven't got any
um but I can tell you uh Matt French was
very upset that that Lang was was in
there thank you that's
helpful seeing no other questions thank
you so much for your testimony and
narrowing it down to that time really
you um and I just wanted to see if
anybody else wanted to speak I don't
have any other pink cards so with that I
will close our meeting um of the special
Committee of the depart on the
department of children youth and
families and I thank everybody for their
time I thank everybody for their
testimony and um I'm looking forward to
us um working to figure out those
policies and procedures and seeing if
there are breakdowns um because the
testimony suggests that there may be and
perhaps we can fix that and find some
some Pro some solutions for the families
to
e
we'll get it in the calendar when we do
that um it'll be a Monday I'm not sure
probably shouldn't be Eclipse Monday um
we'll we'll see if we can uh schedule
one next week or if it would make sense
eclipse probably after the eclipse
perfect so we will do it the US people
yes
okay so we can try and schedule it
tough